how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and we have some news today Marvel
Studios has announced a new television
show coming to Hulu
that's right Marvel Studios Hulu and ABC
signature studios have teamed up to
bring us hellström now this has actually
been in the works for a while now and
while we're getting hellström we were
actually supposed to at the same exact
time get a Ghost Rider TV series for
Hulu as well and this was supposed to be
Gabriel Luna from agents of shields
Ghost Rider
now unfortunately but kind of
fortunately they cancelled a Ghost Rider
and hopefully they cancelled it so they
could use him in the actual Marvel
Cinematic Universe but they did not
cancel Hellstrom hellström is coming and
they have released the official logo for
it now there's actually something that's
kind of interesting about the logo that
we need to dive into because it could
have an impact on the actual MCU and
we'll also talk about who exactly
hellström is and what the show is going
to be about in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all your recent Marvel
content and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a Wolverine
Funko pop all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment down below about the
video now for those of you who are not
aware of what hellström is going to be
about hellström is about damon and
santana hellström Damon and Santana are
the son and daughter of Satan and a
mortal woman
their father raised them in the magical
and demonic arts but when their mother
found out that their father was actually
Satan she went mad she was thrown in a
mental institution and Satan was
banished back to hell the siblings were
then split up but Santana continued to
do some work for her father while Damon
went a different route Damon would end
up going on to fight the forces of his
father including his sister Santana he
would go on to become a very very close
ally of ghostwriters and he would also
go along to fight with the defenders
now hellström is supposed to take place
inside of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
however they have revealed that the
events from hellström will not cross
into the events of the MCU rather the
MCU will affect what happens in
hellström much like agents of shield but
what's really interesting is that we
don't actually see any Marvel
Marvel Studios logo on the official
hellström logo it just simply says a
Hulu original so we might not get too
much involvement in the MCU from
hellström this series will more than
likely be like agents of shield Jessica
Jones the defenders Luke Cage iron fist
that's more than likely the vibe that
it's going to be and even though we
won't see the events of hellström in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it still is
going to play a rather big impact you
see this was supposed to be the first
television series from Marvel that's
supposed to introduce the adventures and
to fear franchise for Marvel Studios in
this adventures into fear franchise we
were going to get different types of
Marvel television shows they're supposed
to be darker and more gritty and we're
having characters like hellström and
Ghost Rider
but then Ghost Rider was pulled and it's
believed that it was pulled because
Kevin Feige actually wants to use Ghost
Rider in the MCU and right now rumors
say he wants to use him because they are
going to explore this adventures into
fear category in the actual Marvel
Cinematic Universe and they're going to
do this by establishing the Midnight's
sons
these characters are supposed to consist
of Moon Knight Ghost Rider
blade Doctor Strange and other
characters that have mystical
connections and kind of demonic
connections as well and this could lead
to the introduction of Mephisto and
really open up the MCU for very
different types of films darker films
that involve monsters and demons and the
type of films that aren't really
designed for kids but designed more for
adults so this really is the start of a
new era for Marvel because there are
tons of really dark and gritty comics
that Marvel hasn't really dived into yet
but with their adventures and to fear TV
series that they have coming out on Hulu
and their midnight sons plans for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we're finally
going to get these characters so the MCU
is actually expanding in a pretty big
way and this new series is supposed to
be pretty dang good if you're interested
in watching it it's scheduled to come
out at the end of this year 2020 on Hulu
but let me know your thoughts about this
more darker more adult rated Marvel
television show coming along with the
midnight sons and the MCU leave all your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to Marvel and the
MCU for live updates you can follow me
on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof